informations sur les jeux olympiques de
2024 appel à projets appel d'offres ou
encore emploi en lançant la plateforme
entreprises 2024 le medef souhaite faire
profiter les entreprises de cette
opportunité économique le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines sera
particulièrement concernée puisque
quatre sites accueilleront des épreuves
le rendez-vous est dans six ans et
pourtant c'est maintenant qu'il faut
anticiper on n'a pas du tout droit à
l'erreur c'est la planète qui nous
regardent et c'est un vrai facteur de
rayonnement pour la france que d'avoir
l'accueil de ces jeux olympiques
donc on ne peut pas se louper et donc
c'est de la préparation et de la
planification la plateforme entreprises
2024 également dédié aux associations
sera mise en route dès le 1er octobre
2018 pour l'instant aucun chiffre précis
sur les retombées économiques
les jeux olympiques devrait néanmoins
créé 250 mille emplois pour 50 ans avec
les sites qui existent déjà il ya une
part hôtelière il part dans le bâtiment
c'est une vraie opportunité s'il ya un
manque de main d'oeuvre présence
certains secteurs et on mettra en place
des formations en adéquation avec la
demande
lors de cette présentation de sportif
françois pervis et quentin lafargue ont
partagé avec les entrepreneurs leur
parcours et leur motivation pour
atteindre le plus haut niveau
quand on est
patron d'une entreprise ou salarié ou
collaborateurs on a des objectifs de
réussite
et forcément quand on est sportif de
haut niveau c'est la même chose tout
comme les sportifs les entrepreneurs
yvelinois pourront mettre toutes leurs
chances de leur côté grâce à cette
plateforme pour profiter au mieux de
l'événement